Tout le reste, 85% de l'univers,
n'émet et n'absorbe pas la lumière.
On ne peut pas le voir avec nos yeux,
ni le détecter avec des ondes radio
ou des micro-ondes, ou n'importe quel autre type de lumière.
Mais on sait qu'il existe
en raison de son influence sur ce que l'on peut voir.
C'est un peu comme si on voulait cartographier notre planète entière
et dessiner tout ce qui s'y trouve
en utilisant cette photographie nocturne de la Terre vue de l'espace.
Les lumières indiquent où se trouvent certaines choses,
mais beaucoup reste invisible,
que ce soient les gens ou les chaînes de montagnes.
Il faut déduire ce qu'il y a à l'aide des indices limités.
Ce qui est invisible est appelé « matière noire ».
Alors, beaucoup de gens ont déjà entendu parler de matière noire
mais même si c'est le cas,
cela vous paraît probablement abstrait,
distant, peut-être même sans intérêt.
Eh bien, ce qui est intéressant,
c'est qu'il y a de la matière noire tout autour de nous
et probablement ici même.
En fait, des particules de matière noire
pénètrent probablement votre corps en ce moment,
alors que vous êtes assis dans cette salle,
parce qu'on est sur Terre,
et que la Terre tourne autour du Soleil,
et que le Soleil avance à toute allure à travers notre galaxie
à environ 800 000 km/h.
Mais la matière noire ne nous heurte pas,
elle nous traverse simplement.
Alors, comment en apprendre plus ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est
et quel est son rapport avec notre existence ?
Eh bien, pour savoir comment nous sommes arrivés là,
il faut d'abord comprendre comment notre galaxie en est arrivée là.
Voici une photographie actuelle de notre galaxie, la Voie Lactée.
Comment était-elle il y a 10 milliards d'années ?
A quoi ressemblera-t-elle dans 10 milliards d'années ?
Qu'en est-il des histoires des centaines de millions d'autres galaxies
que nous avons déjà cartographiées en sondant le ciel en masse ?
Comment seraient leurs histoires
si l'univers était fait de quelque chose d'autre
ou s'il contenait plus, ou moins de matière ?
Ce qui est intéressant à propos de ces modèles d'univers,
c'est qu'ils nous permettent de tester ces possibilités.
Revenons au premier moment de l'univers,
juste une fraction de seconde après le Big Bang.
A ce premier instant,
il n'y avait pas de matière du tout.
L'univers augmentait de volume très rapidement
et la mécanique quantique nous assure que de la matière est créée et détruite
tout le temps, à chaque instant.
Pendant ce temps, l'univers se gonflait si vite
que la matière créée ne pouvait plus être détruite.
Nous pensons donc que toute la matière a été générée à cette époque-là ;
que ce soit la matière noire
ou la matière habituelle, qui nous constitue, vous et moi.
Maintenant, allons un peu plus loin,
après la création de la matière,
après la formation des protons et des neutrons,
après la formation de l'hydrogène,
environ 400 000 ans après le Big Bang.
L'univers était chaud, dense et très homogène,
mais pas parfaitement homogène.
Cette image, prise par Planck, un télescope spatial,
nous montre la température de l'univers,
dans toutes les directions.
Ce que l'on voit, c'est que certains endroits
étaient un peu plus chauds et plus denses que d'autres.
Les tâches de cette image
représentent les endroits qui contenaient le plus ou le moins de masse
au début de l'univers.
La gravité a fait grossir ces tâches.
L'univers s'étendait et perdait globalement en densité,
sur les 13,8 derniers milliards d'années.
Mais la gravité a travaillé dur dans ces endroits
où il y avait un peu plus de masse,
et a attiré encore plus de masse dans ces régions.
Alors, tout cela est assez difficile à imaginer,
laissez-moi donc vous montrer ce dont je parle.
Ces modèles informatiques nous permettent de tester ces idées.
Jetons un œil à l'un d'entre eux.
Ce film, fait par mon groupe de recherche,
nous montre ce qui arrive à l'univers après ses premiers instants.
Voyez-vous, l'univers était très homogène au début,
mais certaines régions contenaient plus de matière.
La gravité s'est mise en marche et en a apporté de plus en plus,
dans les endroits qui sont nés avec plus de masse que les autres.
Au fil du temps,
il y a assez de choses dans un seul endroit
pour que l'hydrogène gazeux,
qui était bien mélangé à la matière noire à l'origine,
commence à s'en séparer,
refroidisse, forme des étoiles
et constitue une petite galaxie.
Peu à peu, pendant des milliards et des milliards d'années,
ces petites galaxies se sont percutées entre-elles,
se sont fusionnées et sont devenues des galaxies plus grandes
comme notre galaxie, la Voie Lactée.
Néanmoins, que se passe-t-il s'il n'y a pas de matière noire ?
Sans matière noire,
les tâches ne s’agglutinent jamais assez.
Il se trouve qu'il faut au moins un million de fois la masse du Soleil
dans une région dense
avant de pouvoir former des étoiles.
Et sans matière noire,
il n'y a jamais assez de choses dans une seule zone.
Voici deux univers côte à côte.
Dans le premier, vous pouvez voir
une agglutination rapide.
Dans cet univers,
c'est très facile de former des galaxies.
Dans l'autre univers,
les petites tâches du départ
restent minuscules.
Pas grand chose ne se passe.
Dans cet univers, on n'obtiendrait pas notre galaxie,
ou n'importe quelle autre galaxie.
Il n'y aurait ni la Voie Lactée,
ni le Soleil,
ni nous.
Nous ne pourrions pas exister dans cet univers.
Bon, donc cette chose folle qu'est la matière noire,
constitue la plupart de la masse de l'univers, elle nous traverse,
nous ne serions pas ici sans elle,
qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Aucune idée.
(Rires)
Nous avons toutefois des suppositions logiques
et beaucoup d'idées de méthodes pour en savoir plus.
La plupart des physiciens pensent que la matière noire est une particule
assez similaire aux particules subatomiques que nous connaissons,
comme les protons, les neutrons et les électrons.
Quoi que ce soit,
elle se comporte comme ces particules en ce qui concerne la gravité.
Mais elle n'émet et n'absorbe pas de lumière,
et elle traverse la matière normale,
comme si elle n'était même pas là.
On aimerait savoir quelle particule c'est,
par exemple, savoir quelle est sa masse
ou savoir si quelque chose se passe
lorsqu'elle interagit avec la matière normale.
Les physiciens ont plein de bonnes idées sur ce qu'elle pourrait être,
ils sont très créatifs, mais c'est très difficile,
car ces idées couvrent un énorme éventail de possibilités.
Elle pourrait être aussi petite que les particules subatomiques
ou aussi massive que cent soleils.
Alors, comment comprendre ce que c'est ?
Les physiciens et les astronomes
ont beaucoup de méthodes pour chercher la matière noire.
L'une des choses que l'on fait, c'est de disposer des détecteurs sensibles
dans des mines souterraines profondes,
pour attendre la possibilité
qu'une particule de matière noire, qui nous traverse nous et la Terre,
heurte un matériau plus dense
et laisse une trace de son passage.
Nous recherchons la matière noire dans le ciel,
car il se peut que des particules de matière noire se heurtent
et créent une lumière très énergétique que nous pourrions voir
à l'aide de télescopes spéciaux à rayons gamma.
Nous essayons même de fabriquer de la matière noire, ici, sur Terre,
en forçant des collisions de particules et en observant ce qui se passe,
à l'aide du Grand collisionneur de hadrons, en Suisse.
Alors, à ce jour,
avec toutes ces expériences, nous savons ce que la matière noire n'est pas,
mais pas encore ce que c'est.
Il y avait de très bonnes idées sur ce qu'elle pouvait être,
que les expériences auraient pu démontrer.
Rien n'ayant été observé, il faut donc continuer de chercher
et de se creuser la tête.
Une autre façon d'obtenir un indice sur ce qu'est la matière noire
est d'étudier les galaxies.
Nous avons déjà parlé
du fait que les galaxies n'existeraient même pas
sans matière noire.
Ces modèles prédisent aussi plein d'autres choses sur les galaxies :
leur distribution dans l'univers,
leurs mouvements,
leur évolution avec le temps.
Nous pouvons tester ces prédictions en observant le ciel.
Laissez-moi simplement vous donner deux exemples
de mesures que l'on peut faire sur les galaxies.
La première : on peut cartographier l'univers avec les galaxies.
Je participe au programme « Dark Energy Survey »,
qui a élaboré la plus grande carte de l'univers pour le moment.
Nous avons mesuré les positions et les formes de cent millions galaxies,
en observant un huitième du ciel.
Cette carte nous montre toute la matière dans cette région du ciel,
qui est déduite de la déformation de la lumière provenant de ces galaxies,
la lumière déformée par toute la matière
qui se situait entre nous et les galaxies.
La gravité exercée par la matière est assez forte
pour dévier la trajectoire de la lumière
et cela nous donne cette image.
Ce genre de cartes
peuvent nous informer sur la quantité de matière noire,
sur sa position dans l'espace
et sur son évolution au cours du temps.
On essaie donc d'apprendre ce qui compose l'univers
à une échelle gigantesque.
Il se trouve que les plus petites galaxies de l'univers
nous fournissent les meilleurs indices.
Pourquoi donc ?
Voici deux univers simulés,
avec deux types différents de matière noire.
Les deux images montrent une région
autour d'une galaxie comme la Voie Lactée.
Vous pouvez voir beaucoup d'autres objets autour d'elle,
de petits regroupements.
Sur l'image de droite,
les particules de matière noire se déplacent plus lentement
que celles de gauche.
Si ces particules de matière noire se déplacent très vite,
la gravité des petits regroupements
n'est pas assez forte pour ralentir les particules rapides,
qui continuent leur chemin.
Elles ne s'arrêtent jamais dans les petits paquets,
il y a donc moins de paquets à gauche que dans celui de droite.
Sans ces petits regroupements,
il y a moins de petites galaxies.
Dans le ciel de l'hémisphère sud,
on peut apercevoir deux de ces petites galaxies,
les plus grandes des petites galaxies en orbite autour de la Voie Lactée :
le Grand Nuage de Magellan et le Petit Nuage de Magellan.
Ces dernières années,
nous en avons détectées bien plus, même de plus petites encore.
Voici l'une d'entre elles,
détectée par le programme « Dark Energy Survey »,
celui qu'on utilise pour cartographier l'univers.
Ces toutes petites galaxies,
certaines sont minuscules,
certaines n'ont que quelques centaines d'étoiles,
par rapport aux centaines de milliards d'étoiles de la Voie Lactée.
Cela les rend très difficiles à trouver.
Mais durant cette dernière décennie,
nous en avons trouvé beaucoup,
nous connaissons maintenant 60 petites galaxies
qui orbitent notre Voie Lactée.
Ces petites choses donnent de grands indices sur la matière noire.
Car rien que l'existence de ces galaxies
nous dit que la matière noire ne peut pas se déplacer très vite
et que rien ne semble se passer lorsqu'elle heurte de la matière normale.
Dans les prochaines années,
nous allons cartographier le ciel avec une bien meilleure précision.
Cela nous aidera à peaufiner nos films
de l'univers entier et de la galaxie.
Les physiciens font aussi de nouvelles expériences, plus minutieuses,
afin d'essayer de capturer un signe de la matière noire dans leurs labos.
La matière noire représente encore un immense mystère
mais c'est très palpitant de travailler dessus en ce moment.
Nous avons des preuves incontestables qu'elle existe,
à l'échelle des plus petites galaxies
et à l'échelle de l'univers entier.
Est-ce qu'on la trouvera et comprendra ce que c'est ?
Aucune idée,
mais cela va être amusant d'en découvrir davantage.
Beaucoup de découvertes sont possibles
et nous apprendrons assurément plus
sur ce qu'elle fait et sur ce qu'elle ne fait pas.
Que l'on trouve bientôt cette particule ou non,
j'espère vous avoir convaincu
que ce mystère est en fait très proche de chez nous.
La recherche de la matière noire
pourrait être la clef d'une nouvelle compréhension de la physique
et de notre place dans l'univers.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)